Hi everybody.
I hope this stream is working.
My name is Nicolas Garnier.
I'm a developer advocate
working on Google
Drive here in Zurich.
So this is the first time
we're trying this live
broadcasting set up.
Hopefully everything
will be live.
If it's not, please complain
on the YouTube comment, and
I'll try to have a look
during this web cast.
So during the session, today
we're going to have a look at
how the search feature inside
Google Drive is working and
basically, as a developer, what
you have to do to make
your file searchable.
And, basically, have a very nice
integration between your
app and Google Drive and have
all sorts of files.
We'll see in details how that
works searchable through
Google Drive.
So first, let's see a bit how
Google Drive search works,
today, for the basic
use cases.
So let me switch to
my drive here.
So this is my drive.
This is one of my
test accounts.
It doesn't have many
files in it.
But what I want to show you is
the search feature, which you
can use using the search
bar here on top.
Whenever you're going to upload
a file to Google Drive,
Google Drive is, usually, going
to index that file.
Basically, read the content of
that file and index it so that
your file can be easily
searchable using that future.
So this is true for,
basically, all
the common file types.
So let's say you upload a text
document, or an HTML
document, or PDF.
Basically, every very, very
common file types.
Google Drive is going to
automatically be able to read
the content because Google Drive
knows that file type and
is going to be able to read and
index that file content.
So I have prepared a little
bit of code here.
Let me switch to my eclipse.
That first little code sample
here is actually using our
Java Quick Start, which I took
from our documentation.
I just modified it a bit so I
don't have to go through all
the authorization part
of that Quick Start.
It's already authorized.
What it's going to do is, it's
simply going to go upload a
text file, which I call
document.text.
Here I can show you.
This is the text file, very
simple text file, with only a
little word in it.
Test one, two, three.
So we can use that to try
to search it later on.
What that's going to do here
is, that's simply going to
upload that text file.
So let me do this.
I run that little script.
Test command file upload.
The code is running.
And when it's done here,
basically, the output tells me
that the insert was
successful.
Now, let me go back
to my drive.
And we see the text file here.
So just to show you that the
indexing is working properly,
if I try to search for test123,
which is the content
of that text file,
that works well.
The file is found.
Everything works as expected.
So if you, as a developer,
upload any types of very, very
common file types.
As I said, PDF, HTML, text
files, that sort of files.
Google Drive is going to
automatically index it.
So if you're working with common
files types, you don't
really have anything else to do
than simply uploading the
text files, as usual.
It also works with images.
So here is an image that
I uploaded earlier.
It's an image of a little
Android logo here.
Google Drive also have some
image recognition logic.
And basically, it's going to
index all the images and then
try to detect a bunch of
patterns or known--
for example, known buildings,
or anything like that.
Or here it's going to recognize
that it's a little
Android doll.
And it's going to index that
file against that search
query, which is, for example,
Android here.
So if I search for Android, I'm
going to find that image
even though the word Android
wasn't used in any of the
metadata for that file.
It's not in the title.
It's not in the description.
So just recognize it's
an Android doll.
That's going to work for all
the images automatically.
You have nothing special
to do here.
If you upload an image, the user
will be able to search
for it, and it will
automatically recognize its
contents, usually.
That works pretty nicely.
A quick note, you also should
be able to use that
feature in the API.
So you can use our full text
search feature in the API.
And you'll get--
for example, if you search
for Android, you'll
actually get that file.
So this is all working
pretty nicely.
Let me go back to
my actual files.
Now I actually want to show
you what you can do as a
developer for uncommon
file types.
If you upload file types
that are not very
common, let's say--
Here, I have prepared another
file, which I'm going to give
that very, very long name.
And I'm going to give it
a very weird MimeType.
The MimeType for that file is
going to be myown/mime.type.
So it's an uncommon MimeType,
I would say.
Google Drive is not going to try
to index that file, as we
are going to see in a minute.
So let me just upload it.
OK, here.
My script is uploading
that file.
That file is actually the same
text file that we've seen
before that contains test123.
three.
Except that because the MimeType
type set for that
file is not plain slash text,
Google Drive is not going to
try to read the files
contents.
And as we can see when I go
back to my Drive here.
OK, my file is uploaded here.
This file content is not
automatically indexed because
it has an uncommon MimeType.
That's the name I
gave to my file.
And if I search for test123
again, I'm only going to see
the first file that
I've uploaded.
Not the second one, which has
the special MimeType.
So now we're going to see
what you can do, guys.
As developers, when you upload
uncommon file types inside
Google Drive, what you can do
to have the content of the
file indexed by Google Drive.
So there is two ways
to have the
content of the file indexed.
Basically, you have to think
in which case am I. Let me
switch back to me here.
Hi guys, again.
Is the content of the
file readable?
If the content of your
file is text--
for example, you're using
XML as a data
format for your file.
Basically, you would think, A,
it's going to be very easy for
Google Drive to simply read that
file content and index it
as it would for a regular XML
file or an HTML file, except I
have my own specific MimeType.
Or, let's say, the other case
you could be in is, I'm
uploading, for example,
binary data.
Or I'm using a shortcut file.
We'll see what a shortcut
file is in
Google Drive in a moment.
So if you're opening binary
data, basically data that
Google cannot read, that's
another case here.
And there is ways for
you to indicate
what type of content--
I mean how Google Drive
should index the
content of that file.
So let me switch back
to my eclipse here.
I've prepared, again, some more
code sample for you here.
So this is the first
case here.
We have a special feature that
you can set to tell Google
Drive that-- let me show
you my eclipse--
that basically tells Google
Drive my thought is actually
text based or XML based.
You can actually read
the content of that
file and index it.
You can do that by simply
setting that little flag here
when you upload the file to
Google Drive that I've
highlighted.
Very simply, you set
use content as
indexable text true.
If you're using the original
[INAUDIBLE]
library or if you're using the
protocol directly, you could
use your parameter content as
indexable equal true when you
do the upload request
to Google Drive.
So when you do that, Google
Drive is actually going to try
to read the file content
as if it was text
and index its content.
So let me run that little
code sample here.
So the sample is uploading
the file.
Here, it's done.
If I go back to my Drive,
let me see all items.
This is here.
My new file just appeared.
This content is automatically
indexed because we tell Google
Drive to do so.
If you search for the content
that's inside that text file,
which has a specific MimeType
type which is not plain dot
slash text.
Google Drive have actually found
it because that's what
setting that little URL
parameter does.
Google Drive just reads it
as if it was a text file.
So you can do that if your
specific file type is any
types of plain text or
XML or JSON based.
Basically, anything that you
guys can read pretty easily.
That's your first case.
Now, the second case is, let's
say your file type is
basically binary.
Basically, Google Drive is
never going to be able to
actually read it.
It's your custom binary file
format you've come up with.
Or it's like an encrypted
file that
you've encrypted customly.
Google Drive is never going
to be able to read the
content of that file.
What you want to do,
in that case, is
use our other feature.
Let me show you.
Here.
Basically, you want to set
the indexable text.
That's part of the
file metadata.
When you upload the file, you
can pass indexable text.
That's a write-only field.
You're not going to be
able to read it back.
The user is never going to be
able to see that field.
We're only going to use all
the words that are in that
field to index your file.
And your file is going
to be searchable.
So let's say you came up with
your own encrypted file or
it's a binary file format.
You have a drawing app,
and it's drawing data.
But the user adds a few text
inside the drawing.
You could, for example, set the
text that is inside the
file content.
Pass it in the
setIndexableText function here.
These words are going to be
indexed for the file to be
searched against.
So let me try to upload
that file again.
This is, again, our
custom file.
I haven't set the little
flag that say to
read the file content.
I'm going to use only that
setIndexableText feature here.
And I'm going to pass,
again, test123 as
the text to be indexed.
So let's run this now.
Here.
Again, my script is uploading
the file.
That's done.
Let me go back to my Chrome.
Let's look at the recent file.
Let's wait a bit.
Here we go.
This is my file here.
No, actually.
Which name did I give it?
Very sorry.
Going back here.
OK.
This is the one here on top.
This file content is not
automatically indexed.
Google Drive is not going to
index the file content per se,
but it's going to index the
value that were passed in the
indexable text field.
So if I search for test123
again, this is the file here.
It's showing up in search.
Again, that's search query
because we've passed it in the
indexable text data basically
when we uploaded the file.
Now there is one last use
case when there is no
content for the file.
You have uploaded no content
for the file.
That's actually called shortcut
files in Google Drive.
We have the special types
of file which are
called shortcut files.
So you don't have to upload
any content when you're
integrating with Google Drive.
You could upload only kind
of like a placeholder.
It looks like a file
to the user.
It's only a placeholder
in Google Drive.
You haven't uploaded any actual
binary or any actual
file content.
Simply the file metadata.
So the title, description,
MimeType, et cetera.
So this is the code here to
upload such shortcut file.
So typically, applications would
upload shortcut files
when they want to keep the
data on the server.
Or let's say they don't have
an actual specific file
format, or it doesn't make sense
for their data to be
bundled in a file, or they
don't want to do that.
They want to keep total
control of the data.
Keep that in their own database,
but they still want
a nice integration with
Google Drive.
So they upload, simply, a
shortcut that when the user is
going to click, the user is
going to be automatically
redirected to this application's
website.
And you can load your data that
you have stored locally
on your own database.
So that's the use case here
for that type of file that
doesn't have any content
on Google Drive.
Though, in that case, you can
still set the indexable text.
We really ask you to do this.
Otherwise, you're going to miss
out on the search feature
for Google Drive.
Because we don't have any
content uploaded at all on
Google Drive, you should really
tell us what's inside
your document and what we should
index for the search to
work on that file.
So here is another code snippet
that I'm going to run.
OK, I'm uploading my
shortcut file.
As you can see here, we don't
actually pass any real file to
be uploaded.
Only metadata for the file is
uploaded to Google Drive.
And when I go to Google Drive,
again, let's look at the
recent file.
This is it.
This file has no content, but
we set the indexable text.
So if I search again for
test123, the file shows up.
So that was here using
the indexable text
for shortcut files.
So again, really, really use
that feature if you're
uploading binary data or if
you're using shortcut files
inside Google Drive.
And for the other use case, in
case your file is actually
text based--
let me switch back again.
Hello again.
If the format of your file is
actually text based and you're
uploading, for example, using
XML or JSON again--
just a reminder--
you could actually, very simply,
use the other feature,
which is simply setting a little
Boolean, a little flag
telling us that it's actually
safe to read the file content.
It's not binary.
It's not crap, basically.
Google Drive can
read the file.
And it's going to try to read
it as text and index that.
And, basically, that's it.
That was Google Drive Search
and how you could
integrate with this.
Thanks again for following
along.
And, again, a warm
hi from Zurich.
We don't very often do these
live demos here, these
Hangouts here.
So hi everybody, and I hope
to see you another time.
All right, bye-bye.